en étant plein coeur de kiev et c'est
une capitale ukrainienne qui on le sent
bien et c'est le grand paradoxe d'un
pays qui est complètement tort guerre
encore et vous le disais parfaitement
c'est à dire que c'est une ville qui
vibre qui essaient de renaître à 1 c'est
ce paradoxe malgré la guerre et le fait
qu'effectivement vous le disiez de
traversée par l'ouest comme nous
l'avions fait il y a deux mois l'ukraine
est aussi saisissant puisque il ya
maintenant véritablement 2 ukraine la
capitale l'ouest qui tente de revivre
évidemment il ya des stigmates de la
guerre ben partout une inflation de 20%
dès que incroyable de gens qui cherchent
de l'essence et puis la vie est
extrêmement difficile il y a des
uniformes un peu partout on voit par
exemple les monuments qui sont encore
protégés pour prévenir quand la ville
était en état de siège les bombardements
mais il y a deux ukraine aujourd'hui
puisque vous le disiez à quelques
centaines de kilomètres de là où je me
trouve sur le front sud ouest et est et
bien les combats font rage mais on sort
est résolument ici ces sept paradoxe
c'est drôle de guerre si j'ose dire
entre cette ville ici de la capitale
kiev qui tente de reprendre ses droits
la vie qui reprend ses droits et en même
temps tous les toutes les yeux qui sont
mobilisés vers le front ouest où les
combats font rage pour ce qui va être
décidé comme étant certainement l'avenir
du conflit entre la russie et l'ukraine